IT?
>> Greg: THIS?
I JUST TOLD YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M OVER IT.
>> Juan: SWITCHING GEARS,
DEMOCRATS TAKING A BIG STEP IN
THE PUSH TO IMPEACH TRUMP.
PASSING A RESOLUTION OUTLINING
HOW IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS WOULD
PLAY OUT IF DEMOCRATS DECIDE
THEY WANT TO MOVE FORWARD.
THE CHAIRMAN JERRY NADLER AND
THE RANKING REPUBLICAN ON THE
COMMITTEE ARE CLASHING OVER THE
MOVE.
>> WITH THESE NEW PROCEDURES, WE
WILL BEGIN NEXT WEEK AN
AGGRESSIVE SERIES OF HEARINGS
INVESTIGATING ALLEGATIONS OF
CORRUPTION, OBSTRUCTION, AND
ABUSE OF POWER AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THE INVESTIGATION WILL GO WELL
BEYOND THE FOUR CORNERS OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
SPEAK OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HAS BECAME A GIANT
INSTAGRAM FILTER TO MAKE YOU APP
INSTAGRAM FILTER TO MAKE YOU APA
INSTAGRAM FILTER TO MAKE YOU APR
INSTAGRAM FILTER TO MAKE YOU APT
INSTAGRAM FILTER TO MAKE YOU APA
SOMETHING THAT IS HAPPENING
THAT'S NOT.
>> Juan: THE PERSON ON THE
SPOT IS NANCY PELOSI.
I THINK SHE IS TORN.
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE SAYS LET'S
HAVE IMPEACHMENT IN ALL THE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO ACTUALLY
GAVE THEM THE MAJORITY, MANY OF
THEM COMING FROM TRUMP MAJORITY
DISTRICTS, WHO DON'T WANT THIS.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK SHE IS
TORN.
SHE MIGHT HAVE A SPLIT WITHIN
THE CAUCUS BUT I THINK SHE KNOWS
VERY WELL THAT IMPEACHMENT IS
NOT A GOOD IDEA AND THAT IS WHY
SHE IS LIKE, OKAY FINE.
GO OUT ASIDE AND PLAY AND
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO COME BACK
FOR DINNER AND WE ARE GOING TO
VOTE ON THE THINGS THAT MATTER
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SHE
WILL LIST THEM OUT.
THERE IS A PARALLEL UNIVERSE
HAPPENING WITH SOME DEMOCRATS
WHO DO WANT IMPEACHMENT.
I DON'T THINK SHE WANTED AND I
THINK SHE PROBABLY THINKS THERE
IS ONLY X AMOUNT OF DAYS BETWEEN
NOW AND THE END OF THE YEAR.
THEY WILL NOT DO IMPEACHMENT
BEFORE THEN.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK
REPUBLICANS WOULD BE DELIGHTED
TO SEE DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE
TRY TO DO IMPEACHMENT?
LOOK AT THESE DEMOCRATS, THEY
ARE JUST HAVING TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE WANTS
IMPEACHMENT AND THAT IS WHAT
JERRY NADLER SAID IN THE LATE
'90s.
YOU SHOULD NOT IMPEACH IF IT IS
A LONG PARTISAN LINES OR IF THE
COUNTRY IS NOT BEHIND YOU
BECAUSE IT IS JUST GOING TO TEAR
THE COUNTRY APART AND NOW HE IS
DOING THE EXACT SAME THING
BECAUSE THERE IS A DIFFERENT
RESIDENT WITH A DIFFERENT LETTER
AFTER HIS NAME IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS LIKE TRYING TO GROUND
YOUR CHILD AFTER THE KIT HAS
ALREADY MOVED OUT OF THE HOUSE.
LET IT GO.
IT IS OVER, DEMOCRATS.
THERE IS NOTHING ON COLLUSION,
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAID
NO OBSTRUCTION.
NANCY IS RIGHT.
THIS IS ONLY GOING TO HURT
PEOPLE IN SWING DISTRICTS.
>> Katie: DID YOU JUST SAY
NANCY IS RIGHT?
>> Juan: KATIE, I THINK THE
TWO THINGS ARE ONE, WHETHER OR
NOT THERE ARE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
GOING TO TRUMP PROPERTIES.
HE IS GETTING OR MAY PEOPLE --
AND THE OTHER ONE IS OBSTRUCTIO
OBSTRUCTION.
>> Katie: I THINK THE ONLY
TAXPAYER DOLLARS HERE ARE BEING
WASTED ON ANOTHER INVESTIGATION.
JERRY NADLER IS ACTUALLY LYING
SAYING THEY'RE GOING TO GO PAST
THE FOUR CORNERS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
NOT TRUE.
HE IS ACTUALLY SENDING OUT
FUND-RAISERS EMAIL SAYING
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY IS OPEN.
THEY ARE BEING DISHONEST AND
WASTING TAXPAYER MONEY.
>> Greg: IMPEACHMENT IS WHAT
YOU GET WHEN YOU HAVE, YOU ARE
LIVING IN A GREAT TIME AND
SUFFERING FROM AMNESIA.
I WASN'T HERE YESTERDAY FOR 9/1
9/11.
IT'S 9/12 AND THEY'RE NOT
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO PREVENT A
NINE THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S A CRIME.
AT LEAST WE KNOW WHAT TRUMP IS